f1 qui est sur un projet qui s'appelle
otto guesde à une mission qui pourrait
remplacer de voice à part dont 20 pour
l'instant c'est un test à côté sans
préparation sous les [ __ ] tout mais
lancement c'est une émission qui sur bbc
one je crois c'est que et on vous a
élevé un petit trailer pour l'april
trailer voici de quoi il est question
on n'a pas après pas
grâce
[Musique]
mais
m
picard
là
[Musique]
oh oui
oui
[Applaudissements]
pas
honnêtement comme ça sont des heures
après on connaît des teasers un pressing
ans était courtisé
alors j'ai bien sûr je n'aime pas mais
je ferai il ya eu l'échec
rising star c'est bien là ce sera le
fiasco du rising star du pauvre c'est
fait c'est une eau nullité cette
émission est bien savez très bien il n'y
a rien il ya des lumières qui s'allument
on ne comprend rien c'est des chanteurs
qui sont plus ou moins doubler par 100
personnes du spectacle de ces français
qui fait 26 tf1 mais ça à l'antenne ce
sera la fin de tf2 est adaptations en
cours en australie au brésil
la seule qui était diffusé c'est en
angleterre sur bbc one ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné veut commander une deuxième
saison
voilà pourquoi tf1 s'il ya des restes
beaucoup ouais mais dont vous avez dit
qu'il aimait pas vous non je n'ai pas
parce que je n'aime pas ce qu'on essaye
terriblement de renouveler le genre télé
crochet mais je cois mai mais je trouve
qu'il n'ya pas évidemment d'intérêt là
dessus et d'ailleurs est un des gros
problèmes pour trouver 100 chanteurs
professionnels avec l'armée le public
c'est un gros problème de casting à le
tuer parce que les enfants un truc
pardon parce que opposé les mines les
chaînes ne change pas dans le
divertissement vous dis donc
notamment car ils n'ont qu'à changer
mais quel manque d'imagination et rocco
et david hiler a résolu l'un porte un
projet qu'on essaie d'adapter on verra
bien ce que ça donne et vous dites ah
non mais on veut on veut des en veut à
mirer tel ou tel truc c'est nul par
principe
cette danse est nul dans tous les cas de
figure alors arrêtons la télévision
revenant livre
[Applaudissements]